[Music]
straight ahead on Law and crime daily
hear from the medical examiner who
performed George Floyd's autopsy I was
aware that at least one video had gone
viral on the internet but I
intentionally chose not to look at that
until I had examined Mr Floyd and more
medical experts weigh in on the Derek
Chauvin trial this was not a sudden
death our legal analysis on this battle
of the experts plus the Floyd family
speaking out as dramatic autopsy photos
are shown in court
lawn crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
and welcome everybody to Long Prime
daily I'm Jesse Weber in for Brian
buckmeyer who's in Minneapolis covering
the Derek Chauvin trial and with us as
always is Terry Austin key testimony for
medical experts on the cause of George
Floyd's death but before we get to that
Brian you have an update on a potential
issue with the jurors that right that's
right Jesse today one of the jurors had
to be approached by the judge and was
questioned about the fact that she may
have seen a media report now she
described it as being without volume
just kind of saw it on TV and then
turned it off very quickly but also that
her mother-in-law had messaged her and
when we heard from the pool reporter it
was definitely that the message said
that was pretty bad now the question is
whether or not the end of that message
was bad for the defense or bad in
general but after questioning by judge
Cahill appropriately so it was found
that she can still remain on the jury
the other thing that was interesting is
for the first time the seat for Derek
chauvin's family was filled by a woman
of Asian descent which made many of us
think it could be his ex-wife based on
what we know of her however from what we
understand it was a family friend and
not his ex-wife hmm interesting all
right thanks Brian now to day nine of
testimony and prosecutors first called a
veteran forensic pathologist who used to
work in the County's medical examiner's
office long crimes and Jeanette Levy's
here to explain her findings as to
George Floyd's cause of death Anjanette
Jesse Dr Lindsay Thomas is actually a
forensic pathologist she knows Dr Andrew
Baker who performed the autopsy on
George Floyd
forensic pathologist Dr Lindsey Thomas
says she's filled out thousands of death
certificates over the years she agrees
with Dr Baker's findings that George
Floyd died of cardiopulmonary arrest
complicating law enforcement subdual
restraint and neck compression did you
rule out drug overdose as a cause of
death yes the point is important to the
prosecution because Derek chauvin's
defense has told the jury Floyd's heart
stopped because of fentanyl use combined
with an adrenaline rush and a bad heart
there's no evidence to suggest he would
have died that night except for the
interactions with law enforcement
Thomas's assessment is similar to Dr
Martin Tobin's that a lack of oxygen to
the brain caused Floyd's heart to stop
the knee remains on the neck for another
3 minutes and 27 seconds after he takes
his last breath
there is the the knee remains after
there's no pulse
the knee remains on the neck for another
two minutes and 44 seconds the defense
has called George Floyd's heart
compromised everyone agrees Floyd's
heart stopped beating they don't agree
on what caused it Dr Michael bodden
prepared an autopsy report for the Floyd
family he's married to law and crime
host Linda Kenny bodden she explains the
difference between a heart attack and
cardiac arrest well a heart attack is
when there's damage to the heart that
causes you to die this is actually your
heart is stopping and
all of our hearts stop when we die on
cross the defense questioned Dr Thomas
about what conclusion she would draw had
police not been involved and she found
Floyd dead at home in that very narrow
set of circumstances
I would probably conclude that the cause
of death was his heart disease
study that examined police restraints of
people in the prone position
these are real people real incidents
right yeah and in those uh 3 000 or so
interactions there were no deaths that
occurred isn't that uh amazing when you
consider that virtually every forensic
pathologist in the United States has
probably had an officer involved death
like this
how did they it utterly baffles me which
is why I kept saying Canada because I
think
I don't know what's different but
it's not responsible
foreign
prosecutors addressed that moment and
many more they asked the doctor how she
didn't didn't know how to interpret the
study she said she didn't know how to
because it's so different from her
experiences here in the United States
Jesse all right thanks Anjanette let's
bring Terry and Brian back in to break
this down now Terry do you think it was
wise for the prosecution to call Dr
Thomas knowing that Dr Baker would also
testify about the autopsy
I do think it was a good move because Dr
Thomas really described both the autopsy
and the death certificate in layman's
terms that the jury could really
understand if you notice Dr Baker was a
little bit more clinical and what she
testified about was there's no question
as Anjanette said that this was a
cardiopulmonary arrest everybody's heart
stops at some point but what she was
able to clarify is one this was a murder
and that's what the autopsy said and two
she was able to clarify the fact that it
was associated with law enforcement
subdural restraint and compression and I
think that's the important part and she
got that across very clearly with the
jury Brian what did you hear about how
the jury was reacting to the doctor's
testimony
yeah so I'm not sure if it's the doctor
or the attorney Jerry Blackwell because
the two are somewhat tied together but
from what we're hearing in the jury pool
is that every time Jerry Blackwell
stepped up to the podium more pens were
picked up they started writing down and
notes on what was being said how was
being said uh I think Dr Tobin might
have been the star of the previous
testimony Jerry Blackwell is putting on
more of this medical testimony and
showing that he can kind of persuade and
Captivate the jurors through multiple
Witnesses
and what's interesting is that usually
this would be dry testimony but I think
everybody's been pretty captivated by it
and I know it's impossible to know
what's going on in a jury member's mind
but it is interesting that they seem to
be paying attention to those particular
Parts still ahead on Law and crime daily
the Floyd family on the loss of their
loved one but first that all-important
testimony from the man who performed the
autopsy on George Floyd what the chief
medical examiner had to say next
[Music]
now back to the Derrick shovin trial and
the highly anticipated testimony from
the County Medical Examiner who
performed George Floyd's autopsy Dr
Andrew Baker
now in Mr Floyd's case you listed the
immediate cause of death as
cardiopulmonary arrest complicating law
enforcement so dual restraint and neck
compression correct
what does cardiopulmonary arrest mean
that's really just fancy medical lingo
for the heart and the lungs stopped
the heart no pulse no breathing
so Dr Baker can you tell us how it is uh
physiologically that the subdual
restraint and neck compression caused Mr
Floyd's death
in my opinion the physiology of what was
going on with Mr Floyd on the evening of
May 25th is
you've already seen the photographs of
his coronary arteries so that you know
you know he had very severe underlying
heart disease I don't know that we
specifically got to it counselor but Mr
Floyd also had what we call hypertensive
heart disease meaning his heart weighed
more than it should
um so he has a heart that already needs
more oxygen than a normal heart by
virtue of its size and it's limited in
its ability to step up to provide more
oxygen when there's demand because of
the narrowing of his coronary arteries
now in the context of an altercation
with other people that involves things
like physical restraint that involves
things like being held to the ground
that involves things like the pain that
you would incur from having your you
know your cheek up against the asphalt
an abrasion on your shoulder
those events are going to cause stress
hormones to pour out into your body
specifically things like adrenaline and
what that adrenaline is going to do is
it's going to ask your heart to beat
faster it's going to ask your body for
more oxygen so that you can get through
that altercation and in my opinion the
the law enforcement sub dual restraint
and the net compression was just more
than Mr Floyd could take by virtue of
that those heart conditions
prosecutors then asked Dr Baker why he
didn't list drugs found in Floyd's
system in his cause of death
well the top line of the cause of death
is really what you think is the the most
important thing that precipitated the
death
um other things that you think played a
role in the deaf but were not direct
causes get relegated to what's known as
the other significant conditions part of
the death certificate so the other
significant conditions are things that
played a role in the deaf but didn't
directly cause the death so for example
you know Mr Floyd's use of fentanyl did
not cause the subdule or neck restraint
his heart disease did not cause the
um the subduol or the neck restraint
okay let's break this down Brian does
having Dr Baker testify on a Friday
afternoon after all these medical
experts have testified does that have
any significance to you whether it's for
the prosecution or the defense
absolutely so the prosecution has the
ability the ability sorry to control
when Witnesses testify so for them they
want to try to put in Dr Baker and his
as they perceive phenomenal testimony so
that the jury is left with that for
Friday night Saturday Sunday and Monday
morning yeah they're not going to talk
to other people hopefully they follow
the rules but it's not like they're
going to be able to take that part of
their brain and lay it down and not
think about it through that whole
weekend but as a defense attorney you
want to try to attack that as best as
possible so that your words ring true in
their minds for that three days and
hopefully will solidify when they come
back on Monday Terry I thought I thought
this was interesting Dr Baker testified
that he didn't view the videos until
after he completed the autopsy should he
have looked at the videos to determine
the terminal event
you know I thought that was interesting
too he definitely said he did not want
that to influence his autopsy and to me
if the terminal event is the fact that
the knee and the other pressure on the
back caused the death I would think that
he would want to see all of that it
seems like that would be very important
to his decision regarding the manner and
cause of death you know what is most
important is at the end of the day he
did say even though there were these
other contributing factors like the
heart condition like maybe some drug use
in the adrenaline the ultimate result
was that this death was caused by the
subdural compression and restriction on
the neck and so I think that he really
did bolster what the prosecution is
trying to get across and we are seeing
this consistent theme with the
prosecution with a number of these
medical experts talking about cause of
death and it begs the question who will
the defense call as their experts to
ultimately rebut this testimony it'll be
interesting to watch now coming up on
Long crime daily more medical experts
testify did George Floyd die due to a
knee on his neck or an overdose plus the
Floyd family speaking out after dramatic
courtroom moments more on that spark of
Life testimony on their brother father
and friend
[Music]
as a Derek Chauvin trial finishes up its
second week of testimony all eyes may be
on the defendant but it's those who love
George Floyd that may be feeling the
biggest impact long primes Kim Johnson
is in Minneapolis and she spoke with the
Floyd family Kim
yeah Jesse when it comes to George
Floyd's family it has been a difficult
day in court a day they've been bracing
for seeing the autopsy photos of their
loved one for the first time now the
photos were not displayed on monitors or
broadcast to the public instead they
were printed and passed out to every
Journey every person in the room
including Rodney Floyd George Floyd's
brother who was in the room as a family
representative earlier this week
Reverend L Sharpton held a prayer vigil
to provide comfort for the family and
community in light of the release of
these photos and the family's hardship
watching the videos capturing George
Floyd's last moments being played over
and over again in court the lones Floyd
another brother of George Floyd's says
the emotions are overwhelming
it's difficult watching him scream until
it's loud and being tortured to death
and also they tried to say that he died
another thing you have to look at when
you think about that it's millions of
Americans around the world who are
addicted to their self-medicated and
that's the thing that we have to
understand is we gotta help people
now he's referring to the defense's
argument that Floyd died as a result of
a drug overdose and not law enforcement
restraints regarding the autopsy images
a pool reporter in the courtroom says
Rodney Floyd spent a long time staring
at the first one which showed a close-up
photo of Floyd with a white tube
protruding from his mouth from emergency
respiratory efforts and a scrape over
the left eye Brow and cheek now the
state is able to call what's called
spark of Life Witnesses these Witnesses
could be someone like George Floyd's
brother who can add additional testimony
about the life of an alleged crime
victim humanizing them and showing the
jury that they are not faceless Jesse
Kim is your understanding that George
Floyd's brother has been sitting in
court during the trial
that's right yes he does have three
brothers that have been taking turns uh
changing it up every day who's in court
sometimes they'll come just for the
afternoon and they'll switch out during
the afternoon break only maybe staying
for an hour an hour or two as you can
imagine it's very difficult and taxing
on them they tell me to stay for the
entire day also George Floyd's nephew
who uh thought of him as more of a
father has been in the courtroom uh his
sister Bridget however we have seen
glimpses of glimpses of her but she's
been spending the trial volunteering at
a food shelf near the intersection where
George Floyd died so each member of the
family grieving in their own way during
this trial and it must be difficult to
hear as this testimony continues on and
we learn more details of what is
happening and particularly the first
week when there was all those different
camera angles of what happened to George
Floyd all right thank you Kim appreciate
it when we come back medical experts
take the stand hear what another After
hired by the state had to say of George
Floyd's cause of death
welcome back everybody I want to tell
you about the latest in one of our shows
on the law and crime Network Prime crime
a private investigator named Taylor
Wright suddenly goes missing authorities
have several Persons of Interest in mind
different theories and it's even
considered whether the she disappeared
on her own yet it's the police
interviews of Wright's friend crime
scene technician Ashley MacArthur that
changes the whole game
what was Taylor
he didn't tell us where she's at I don't
know
okay if something happened like I said
you're not a bad person you're not a
career criminal this is a person who's
traveled across states to take care of a
friend if something happened tell us
[Music]
hear how strong the evidence was against
the main suspect and from the prosecutor
and defense attorney themselves to see
how it all plays out tune in to Long
crime
back now to Minnesota for the Derrick
shovin trial where the state called an
emergency room physician who trains the
Louisville Kentucky police department on
positional asphyxia now he said he's
reviewed the medical reports and watched
videos and concluded that Floyd's
actions were of someone who died from
lack of oxygen not an overdose
he's breathing
he's talking
he's not snoring he is saying please
please get off of me I want to breathe I
can't breathe that is not a fentanyl
overdose that is somebody begging to
breathe I can't believe it is
I don't believe this man Mom I love you
Mr bruising on Mr Floyd's back that you
were aware of
and that's what there was none bruising
in his neck yes sir either uh
above the skin or below the skin no sir
there was not there's unquestionable
evidence that Mr Floyd had
cardiovascular disease correct that is
correct sir
you'd agree that the Pathologists who
performed the autopsy found a 90 percent
blockage of the right coronary artery
yes sir was there any evidence that you
saw that George Floyd had a heart attack
there was absolutely no evidence at
autopsy of anything that suggested that
Mr Floyd had already did you see any
evidence that Mr Floyd
died of a meth overdose
no sir he did not did you see any
evidence that he died of a fentanyl
overdose no sir he did not
okay let's bring back in Brian and Terry
Brian big picture here we're looking at
these Witnesses one by one how will
either side the prosecution or the
defense just bring all this together
yeah so you got to remember the end of
the day this cross-examination this
direct examination are merely just tools
or points that either side are going to
use for that summation I think right now
the prosecution has a pretty solid story
to tell that the video and the common
sense interesting enough air Nelson used
that term but the common sense of
viewing the video coincides with the
science for Eric Nelson he's got to keep
trying to poke those holes up it's the
heart it's the drugs that killed them
but it seems like the prosecution has
kind of filled up those holes in regards
to what killed George Floyd
Terry if we focus on Dr Smock for a
moment he was on the stand for you know
a good amount of time what stood out to
you the most in his testimony because
clearly he's a crucial witness for the
state
he is crucial and I think he did an
excellent job he not only talked about
medical but he sort of tied it into what
the police should have been doing what
Chauvin should have been doing so he
confirmed that Floyd died of positional
asphyxiation he said that there were no
bruises but you might not necessarily
see bruises in that kind of condition he
said there was no heart attack the heart
looked good he said there wasn't a
fentanyl overdose he explained that with
the fentanyl overdose you might fall
asleep with the meth overdose you might
have a quick heart attack that that
would be sudden so I think he explained
it in terms that the jury could
understand and this is the most
important part he said that CPR should
have been conducted at the time Floyd
was unconscious that was not done so I
think he made the causal connection
between what the police should have done
at the time that George Floyd was
literally dying in front of their eyes
Terry about a minute the prosecution has
been presenting some pretty compelling
and persuasive experts who should the
fence call in and why should the jury
believe them
well I think the defense make sure they
have an
standpoint who can say that
dog overdose and that the cause of death
had to do with his heart and this
adrenaline because so far all of the
medical evidence has talked about that
you know it was this compression and it
was the lack of air so I think he's
going to have to focus on the cause of
death and absolutely focus on whether or
not Chauvin was trained to respond the
way he did some believe that Derek
chauvin's defense was an uphill battle
before the trial started and many might
be wondering after these Witnesses it
became an even steeper uphill battle
Brian Terry thank you so much and
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on Long crime daily daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss Justice in
America
[Music]
foreign